turning now to a power couple who really
needs no introduction that would be a
mall and her husband George as in
Clooney eight years ago Hollywood
royalty George married a mall a
Powerhouse attorney fighting for social
justice together back in 2016 they
founded the Clooney foundation for
justice it's an organization
organization rather that provides free
legal support to victims of abuses of
power tomorrow they are hosting the
first ever Albee Awards it's a new
ceremony to shine a light on individuals
who are devoting their lives to Justice
at Great personal risk to themselves now
this is going to be a star-studded
affair listen to the presenters Meryl
Streep Dua Lipa Oscar Isaacs Julia
Roberts and Michelle Obama in an
exclusive interview the couple joined us
in the studio just yesterday to tell us
all about it
Justice Albie sacks tell us about him
and why this is why you wanted to call
it the album Awards I'll be thacks is a
South African lawyer who is a human
rights hero he fought against apartheid
and he was actually imprisoned and then
he was blown up in a car bomb he lost
his arm he lost sight in one eye but he
never stopped fighting and when Nelson
Mandela got released from prison he
appointed Alby to the Constitutional
Court where he served as a judge for
many years he was one of the people who
drafted the Bill of Rights in South
Africa and when we were thinking of you
know who should win the Lifetime
Achievement Award
um and who we wanted to name the entire
ceremony after he was the first name to
come to mind and we can't imagine anyone
better George I've heard you say you
want to make sure that the people in
cases are not forgotten so a lot of
times it's in the news and then it moves
on and you're determined not to let that
happen it's a hard thing to do you know
listen our news Cycles are interesting
you know we have a 24-hour news cycles
and quite honestly the stories you know
get old you know you've heard it we've
seen it we know it fatigued you can see
this happening in Ukraine right now
right now here's the truth in Ukraine at
some point this war will end at some
point and then they're going to have to
be people held accountable for that part
of what we're doing is gathering the
evidence so that when that moment comes
you have the ability to say now we're
going to hold you responsible how did
you all decide the award categories well
it's basically matching the communities
who we try to help through our work so
women journalists democracy Defenders
survivors of Human Rights abuses and
this group of yasna are really fighting
for free and fair elections and I think
six of them are in jail now I think in
prison the wife of one of them is coming
and uh and we're going to leave an empty
chair for him and she's bringing a
letter from prison that he's going to
read
um you know these are people that
willingly go to prison because they
believe so strongly in in the fight for
Independence in the fight for democracy
they are real heroes one of the awardees
is Maria Russ and you represent her tell
us a little bit about her
Maria is an amazing journalist she
reported on what was happening in her
country corruption and the execution of
civilians in the name of a drug war the
authorities came after her and she's now
facing 70 years in prison it used to be
you know naming and shaming people sure
would force them to behave that no
longer appears to be because it work it
really doesn't work I'd say there is an
effective tool though which is you know
you can't shame uh Omar al-Bashir in in
Darfur in the Sudan right you can't
shame so so George do you call people on
the phone and try to reason with them at
first what do you do I've had this at
work well I've had moments with uh heads
of banks where where I'll say so we have
forensic accountants and they'll say
okay well what we found is you have four
you know you have a you know salvacare
or Iraq machine or somebody from South
Sudan in any number of sort of Bad
actors that have hundreds of Millions of
dollars in your bank and I'm going to do
a press conference tomorrow and uh and
we've got the George Clooney face yes
and we've given and we've also given all
this information to to the treasury
Department so that you know there are
things that can be done it's been said
about you Mrs Clooney that you won't
back down and you don't give up where
does that fight come from for you
goodness I didn't know I think we're
just responding to what we see in the
world and try to use anger as a
motivating force rather than something
that just makes you want to bury your
head in the sand
um I also think you know my mum is a
journalist and and she was always asking
tough questions and not sort of
intimidated by people who are in power
but you know impressed if someone's
actually doing something good and I
think that has stayed with me and and I
think that's something that yeah as well
yes did you ever have advice from your
dad George sure I like him so much too
by the way he's a he's very smart and
very funny and you know I listen and I
know you're very close I took him to uh
Darfur with me we went into Chad and
snuck into Darfur together when he was
75 years old and he's a tough one he's
he you know when I was growing up my dad
had really one rule for us which was
challenge people with more power than
you and defend people with less power
because if you do nothing else in your
life then you'll have had a successful
life and I remember my dad had done a
story I think about in Honduras I think
it was something sort of violent and
awful and the story got bumped for an
Elizabeth Taylor she got the big diamond
ring story right and he was pissed off
of course I said let's go to Darfur you
and me we'll go there and and you be the
reporter and I'll be Elizabeth Taylor
that's the you know there are some
things you can do you know we're not a
government we can't change the laws but
we can make it loud enough that the
citizens can demand those type of things
and you know it it doesn't work easily
and it takes a long time and you know
you keep feeling this you know this Arc
of History bending towards Justice it
feels like it takes a long time it does
yeah George Clooney's dad Nick Clooney
also a journalist they're working very
hard when we come back we'll continue
our conversation with Amal and her
husband the lovely George they're going
to talk about raising their kids and
what George did to win them all's heart
he's clever this George